what up space fam goes in here for anime
uproar and I'm back at it again to
discuss the latest and craziest updates
in the demon slayers story this chapter
moved so fast and we actually made huge
progress and got some huge reveals
compared to the last few chapters so
definitely stay tuned for that if you
enjoyed these weekly Demon Slayer Child
reviews and want to keep them coming the
best thing you can do is smash that like
button and share this video with a
friend if you haven't be sure to
subscribe and this is crucial
hit that notification bell or you will
miss future Demon Slayer videos remember
that you can get early access to these
chapter reviews by following anime up
for audio on Spotify iTunes or wherever
else you listen to podcasts a big thank
you goes out to our glorious patrons who
help make videos like this one possible
more on those amazing people later for
now keep in mind there will be manga
spoilers in this video we are going to
be discussing the latest chapter in the
Demon Slayer series chapter 195 after
all now without further ado let's jump
into it on the cover page of this
chapter we see the beautiful but injured
best girl meet suti and Tamayo is now
demonized cat in part we are shown me to
return - of what a guru who rejoined us
last chapter is fighting for and my lord
a guru is amazing I can't get enough of
this guy and after every chapter he's
proving the people who downplayed him
more and more wrong this chapter is
called bewilderment meaning a feeling of
being confused this is the perfect name
for this chapter because we have so many
twists and turns happening and so many
questions popping up again we have my
boy yo Deecee the strongest demon center
in history mentioned I've noticed that
my love for your ichi is well documented
to the point where people are calling me
anime yo Deecee is the strongest even
certain history uproar in the comments
and I'm totally okay with that in this
chapter we got to fill some gaps that
remained unfilled from the fight against
you and Ichi and moves on I commented in
the recent how strong his moves on video
that moves on look completely confident
before the fight with you Ichi and he
explains why he did in this chapter he
tells us that at first yo Deecee looked
weak which is hilarious I love the fact
that this insanely strong dude looks
weak to others your ichi appears to be
walking around in the selfless state all
the time moves on notices that he didn't
show any drive fighting spirit hatred or
animosity
like a flower blooms without trying to
teach it just naturally kills demons
because that is him following the way of
the universe he's not taking any
pleasure and killing creatures he hates
he's just doing his thing
Musa never thought that this dude could
cut off his head like most he assumes
that a lack of fighting spirit means a
lack of power however that was a big
mistake on Mullins part your DG's
attacks continued to burn Mullins flesh
his very cells for hundreds of years
like sunlight I pointed out that URI Chi
uses the breath of the Sun a key the
power of the Sun to fight so Muslims
only chance of recovering from these
wounds and being immune to the breath of
the Sun style is absorbing mezu KO a
demon West conquered the Sun remember
this because it'll be important for
later the manga is clearly equating the
effects of the breath of the Sun style
with actual sunlight here mu song goes
on to praise your ichi more and I never
get tired of it
he says not even God or Buddha would
have expected your ichi he compares him
to ridiculous myth moves on is convinced
that the real monster was your ichi and
not him i love this last chapter i was
talking about how the mangaka is
humanizing Mouzon he's awful but he's
very human in his fear and frustration
he's not some opie untouchable opponent
rather he's a guy that is traumatized
and frustrated by his own powerlessness
in the face of your ichi he's like an
older brother who keeps losing to his
younger brother in chess he knows he
should be able to win what with being
older and a demon but he keeps getting
destroyed the gap is too big and he just
can't accept it he's a sore loser he
wants to think of himself as perfect as
the greatest but your teaches existence
makes it impossible for Mouzon to
maintain that image of himself Mouzon is
a creature fueled by ego who feels like
he has to be the strongest but loses to
the Eagle as Yuri Chi who just wanted to
carry out his duty and never asked or
expressed a desire to be the strongest
but let's leave moves on psychology to
the side for now and return to this epic
fight Kanjar notices that Mouzon can't
hide his wounds anymore and that's
because he's weakening more and more the
aging poison is becoming more and more
effective and he still hasn't adapted to
it
Thundra points out how they only
God moves on this week with everyone's
help everyone bought time and because of
the way the aging potion works each
second contributed to weakening and
moves on more and more
that's why Tangier has to take advantage
of this opportunity and defeat moves on
we figure out something very interesting
too
the scars should each he left move
across Milan's body they follow his
brains and hearts which is fascinating
Thundra hasn't been able to access the
transparent world because Amazon's
constant attacks however because of the
scars tundra and everyone else can see
Milan's weak spots and fight effectively
against him your Ichi could not have
made it easier for them what with the
trauma and the scars and saving Cameo
who produced the aging potion I feel
like you're Ichi will forever be the MVP
of this series for now tundra figures
that he'll help a girl out who can't
currently see by using you she rose
paper talisman we hear a crow say that
there's 40 minutes left until dawn
another ten minutes have passed since
last chapter if we keep up with this
pace the fight could even be over and
four chapters but I'm thinking we'll
probably have more than that forty
minutes though is too close for comfort
if you ask moves on and he starts
running away which is pretty hilarious
to me I don't know about you but seeing
time shows shocked faces moves on books
it from the fight like Joseph Joestar is
amazing
tundra starts panicking and telling ego
and eager eyes like well obviously the
demon dude has no pride he just clings
to life and he'll do whatever it takes
to stay alive I really like how the
mangaka keeps emphasizing this point how
just clinging to life and prioritizing
survival above all else turns us into
monsters literally in this case this is
why we can't really respect Mouzon he
puts his life above everything else
because he's scared of death he's a
coward and his fear leads him to do
horrible empathetic things I have much
more respect for characters like Kyoto
and mu Ichiro who were ready to bravely
die for a cause greater than themselves
like saving the lives of others Tundra
chases moves on but he's falling behind
also moves on is trampling on the dead
bodies of Tundras fallen comrades Tundra
does not want all of their deaths to
have been for nothing and so he's
extremely worried
imagine if moves on just did all this
damage escape
and came back full power another night
after having adapted to the aging poison
that would be terrible because he pretty
much wiped out the entire Dimas Air
Corps in one night including some of the
strongest pillars that would be a
nightmare so right now the stakes are
super high now's the time to finish
Mouzon off when he's still weakened from
the efforts of the others tundra throws
swords eye moves on in a desperate
effort to get him to stop this has
pretty much become a meme by now you can
expect that Tundra will either headbutt
you or throw swords at you like he did
when Alcazar booked it from the fight
against Kyojin Oh again he's using the
tools of his fallen comrades to help
slow moves on down moves lon has to be
careful because as he says piercing
attacks are more dangerous than slashes
to him right now then let's get all
aboard the hype train because my boy
agura
shows up and pierces the demon king of
Pop right through his frickin neck man
ego rose awesome I'll remind you guys
that physically speaking ego was
revealed to be the second weakest pillar
after Shinobu but his skills and
willpower make him one of the most
dangerous pillars this guy is my top 5
favorite characters for sure and we just
keep getting more and more reasons to
love him the dude loses his eyes and yet
he joins the fight as soon as he can and
even catches up two moves on somehow
what speed what epicness it's also great
that he gets such a solid piercing
attack on Mouzon right after moves on
thinks that it would be bad if the demon
slayers got a piercing attack on him if
this was the anime we'd have some epic
music playing right now it is only then
after ego has already done so much that
tundra wants to give ego to the paper
talismans so he can share Kabuto Maru
site rather than having to wait for his
pet snake to communicate what's going on
to him but man ego is already doing so
well I don't even know if he needs it
honestly the two are fighting against
moves on and you know moves on has to
get some hits on them you know it's only
fair he's the main antagonist of the
series and all let him have his token
hits
however these hits do cause tundra to
lose the paper talisman aka seals he was
holding tundra communicates to eagle
aware the seals are and defense eager
Ofra moves on while he goes to grab them
understandably eager doesn't
perfectly catch such small seals by just
jumping three long strides to the right
but luckily the pet snake kibou dama who
is there with the assist the snake grabs
the papers and I have to admit this was
super hype for me when he got them this
is by far my favorite snake ever I don't
especially like snakes they kind of
freak me out but I absolutely love this
one I will go so far as to say that I
like Kabu Domino more than Tomatoes cat
there I said it
best snake passes one seal to Igor oh
and he begins to see we get a really
cool moment here that's easy to miss
igloo hotel sponge off thank you that
may not seem like a big deal but it is
because it's a guru he's God and don't
get in my way personality he's often
been hard on time zero and he spoke
coldly towards him in the past
especially because he didn't want him
getting close to his precious meet suti
don't get me wrong
ego would always risk his life to save
time zero but he'd also dis him in the
process in a tough love kind of way now
though it seems like chondros truly
earned the snake pillars respect and
this thank you coming from him truly
represents a meaningful shift in their
bromance
in other words their bromance just
leveled up thanks to ton zero Igor can
now see he says it's not like human
sight but he can see better now so
fighting is much easier considering how
well he was already doing when he
couldn't even see this looks super bad
for moose on the two demon Slayers are
persistent as Mullen says they never
give up they keep blocking him off from
escaping we then get a huge reveal from
Mouzon he reveals that his breath is
running out and that his physical
strength won't last much longer he can't
believe this and neither can the reader
probably we have the main big bad boss
man of the series and he's admitting
that conjurer and agura are too much for
him right now
they're going to defeat him if something
doesn't change Kuna Zuko we finally see
Mitsuko holding her eye as she was
before she takes her hand away from a
right eye revealing what looks like a
human eye this is huge people is it a
coincidence that right one moves on
thinks he's about to lose we jump to
mezu code the possible key to his
invincibility I don't think so some of
you think that bazooka is human now so
moves on can't absorb her and become
immune to the Sun
more but don't overlook the fact that
her left eye is still demonic she's not
completely human yet so it's way too
soon to assume that moves on can't
absorb her and become immune to the Sun
and the fact that she's shown up right
as he's against the ropes seems to
suggest that she might help him turn the
tables on the attacking demon slayers
I've been saying that I hope that Zuko
survives because vesikko is lovable and
awesome
however it doesn't look good for her it
is possible that Mouzon will absorb her
adapted a poison become immune to the
Sun and then time show and whoever else
is still around are going to have an
emotional fight against a
new-and-improved moves on obviously the
mangaka left both possibilities open
ethical my turn full human and become
useless to Mouzon or she might not it's
just that right now I can't think of
another way for Mouzon to completely
turn the tables
the mangaka of demon seer has definitely
had villains defeated before they ever
got to show their full power think of
dolma aqua zankoku she bow all of who
were defeated before they arguably
achieved their full power DOMA was
poisoned and aqua zankoku she bow gave
up the will to fight right after they
gained the ability to regrow their heads
like Musa
so moves on could totally die in a
weakened state however for the final
fight the mangaka might want a full
power battle against Mulan in an
upgraded Tangier oh that would be epic
and emotional but the trade-off for that
epic fight might be Meza Cole's life
which is no small price to pay as always
let me know what you think is going to
happen in the next chapter will we see
full power moves on or are they close to
defeating him well let's go come in and
just help control and eager to put the
final nail in the coffin and that is it
for today's video this chapter was my
favorite in a while so many amazing
moments so many twists and turns so much
ego and pet snake epicness and even the
return of our precious new zoo code
I am ultra hyped to see the next chapter
and how Nessa Cole will fit into this
fight if you did enjoy this chapter
review the best thing can do is smash
that like button and share this video
that helps the channel and lets me keep
doing my thing if you haven't be sure to
subscribe in this is crucial
hit that notification bell or you will
miss future demon serie reviews
let me know if you were upset when I
called make sure your best girl near the
beginning of the video or were you like
of course goes on I too and
man of culture and recognize the sexy
Gloria meet suti be honest anyways your
best girl choice aside remember that you
can get early access to these chapter
reviews by following anime upper audio
on Spotify iTunes or wherever else you
listen to podcasts a special thank you
goes out to our patrons over on patreon
who help us survive YouTube issues and
who helped make videos like this one
possible first and foremost I want to
thank our the one tier patrons the ones
who stand atop all clans Stephan and
Radha alo long autumn the world stealers
the school bus
Tyson Kirino a quiet respect and Pat a
heffa and I can't forget our pro hero
tier patrons the one and only Gilgamesh
nothing but a fan Jason Wilson Kings ell
dress fitted ala beat Anatole Cassatt
Suki alpha do angel Cruz team Sparky 65
cricket XP Rohan Kapoor
Jessica Maloney Emperor Taku Timothy
Edward Vargas Jeanne d'Arc Joel Stanton
JCCC waka very Gucci and Jessica Kayla
fond thank you all so much if you enjoy
our work you can support more of it by
going over to patreon comm anime out
drawer and becoming a patron today for
as little as $1 if you do so you'll get
your name featured in future videos
alongside these amazing people right
here and you'll even get access to our
private patron only discord where we
talk about anime life and of course dank
memes so check out patreon.com/lenguin
and until next time see you space cowboy
[Music]
you
[Music]